я приношу глибокі співчуття та знаю
тяжкості цієї втрати і те, що Петро
олексійович сьогодні
поряд з ним немає людини, яка для
будь-якого чоловіка батько це перша опора я
згадую як йшла моя мати коли я
був у в'язниці і задовго до смерті лежав у
тяжкому стані вона сказала я
проклинаю путіну за те, що сльози
мого народу
викликані
його нелюдськими злочинами та
звернулася до порошенка і сказала що
знає що він завжди пам'ятатиме і
боротися за наших синів які
борються за україну я хочу звернутися
сьогодні до представників нової влади та
президенту зеленському, що треба пам'ятати
кожен день
про свою відповідальність вихованості та
знати що люди все бачать все пам'ятають і
уникнути таких проклять тому що
смерть батьків продиктована тим, що ми
боротьбі за свою державу за свій народ
і його переслідуваний за це наші самі
близькі діти дружини
особливо батьки вони це важко
переносять і це часто на жаль
закінчується чекай тимчасова смертю і
сьогодні ось так цинічно переслідувати
людини, яка сприяла тому, щоб
нашої держави була незалежною
який зміг протистояти як
головнокомандувач головного ворога нашої
держави
цинічні дослідники ВОВ і призначити
суд у ці дні його поважають мільйони і не
дай бог бути проклятим мільйони
а Петро Олексійович від друга хочу
звернутись і сказати що цей тираж
який ти несеш у політичній боротьбі
за майбутнє своєї держави за народ
україни це вища така ось оцінка для
ваших батьків і дай боже щоб кожен
виховав
і виростив своїх дітей, так як це
зробив ваші батько і ваша мати